we we are lucky that we have a uh
constitution in this country
otherwise we'd be dealing with the same
fate as canada which is just like a
randomly arresting people or the uk
what is the uk doing more lockdowns they
announced more lockdowns when their
debts have been going down and they're
extending it
or something yeah they're at a four-week
low it continues to go down
but the uk government still is like well
we need to lock down more because of
this indian variant which again doesn't
correlate with the hospitalizations the
cases and the numbers
a lot of this is you know in my opinion
more about control
and when we look at the lockdowns when
we see the larger effects of them
we don't see any efficacy we don't see
any scientific data showing that they
actually helped especially with
states like florida and texas disproving
a lot of the big data
surrounding uh this particular case but
but
what did the lockdowns do they helped
out the billionaire class because the
billionaire class was allowed to be open
amazon walmart costco whatever other
special interest
business as usual you run a church you
run a business you're screwed
and then you know another thing that
happened there's this horrible video i
tweeted it out today
and and it's heartbreaking of a father
being arrested
in front of his children because he
practiced his religion in canada
and held religious services and seeing
videos like that infuriate me
because it also plays into what we were
talking about in the beginning of this
broadcast
these huge waves of violence that are
taking over major cities not just in san
francisco
atlanta new york but hold on that point
you made about the guy getting arrested
remember when the when the pandemic
first started and we saw those videos
out of wuhan
where the chinese authorities were
dragging people out of their homes
and we were like wow china's crazy
and then it happened in canada like
hundreds of times
it happened it even happened here in the
u.s and it's happening right now as
we're speaking
as florida jewish community in new york
city yeah as florida is doing huge open
concerts 12 000 people at the bitcoin
conference
canada you can't even have a religious
service which is absolutely infuriating
and when police officers you know a lot
of their
time a lot of their resources were spent
directly at shutting down businesses
at shutting down church services and
they did it happily
and at the same time what did cities
like new york city do
they released violent criminals onto the
street the resources for the policing
went towards innocent people
innocent people were sent to jail were
prosecuted were punished for doing
everyday
average things and now the united
kingdom's saying we need more lockdowns
so what you're saying is what you're
saying is uh
abolish the police i think there's a
discussion to be had
especially when it comes to policing and
i'm not afraid to say that i
i think that you know we definitely need
to have that conversation especially
with what's happening in atlanta
there was a drive-by shooting there's
videos of police officers standing by
and deciding not to intervene or do
anything because
the mayor banned them from even uh doing
pursuits
in the city of atlanta so there's a
report from michael tracy
about all of the ridiculous covid finds
that police were
were writing for regular people for this
for nonsense there was one story i think
is that in new york
a jewish guy he had his store was closed
but he opened the door for fresh
restaurant and then the cop come or the
health inspect health official was like
we're gonna write you a fund and he's
like why i'm closed like doors open
sorry
it was interesting a year ago because
the churches were all closed
i think it was in pittsburgh a church
group decided to hold their
service in walmart
that was amazing it was so infuriating
to watch
as all of the corporate like we were
talking about luke all the corporate
interests got to keep their businesses
open and the little shops closed down
in my neighborhood like a ton of little
shops are gone and it's
it's sad to see the rite aid is still
there with the gum in cages
they got people to worship the lord in
walmart
they sure did that is okay i'm sorry man
you you you could not have written a
future nightmare dystopia
that like that bad what do you think
because
when they're writing identity four
they're like well people are still like
practicing their religious ceremonies
you know in private
well not really 94 was like worship big
brother but at the very least
man we we could we could we could go for
an uh a a nightmare dystopia where
we go to the corporation for our
religious ceremonies
it's the only place the government
allows it's like wally
yeah that movie was so prescient yeah
man i think you know honestly it's uh
it's
it's mike judge is a prophet yeah idiocy
that was amazing too idiocracy
did you ever see em forrester i mean
it's not a film but he wrote a book
called
the machine stops and it basically it
takes place in the future he wrote it in
what like i think 1911
1918 somewhere around there and
everybody lives in their own little box
everyone lives in their own little cube
they interact with each other through
what's called the machine
they deliver speeches to the machine
they react to each other's lectures
through the machine they ask the machine
to bring them things the machine brings
them
you know someone to sleep with and then
takes their children away and puts them
in a different little box the earth is
uninhabitable
and they don't know how to interact with
one another it's like being in a chicken
coop
it kind of is except it's also kind of
like coveted lockdowns
yeah man idiocracy so what so uh what we
have
uh donald trump as president he's
literally in the wwe hall of fame
he is he actually is yeah he actually is
the actual individual of donald trump
donald trump is in the wwe hall of fame
he was the president of the united
states
and like camacho in idiocracy he's like
this wrestler
so not one for one but so much of that
seems to be coming true and it's it's
rather nightmarish
but you know it's not it's not
completely obviously the movie is very
different
but there's funny things to point out
about it i'll tell you what's really
disconcerting is
when you you look at
the policies coming from democrats the
ideology coming from
the left the things they believe like
like
which one who i think libby you were
mentioning this it was a shifting sander
was that you emma
like shifting sand beneath them yeah
you're saying this they have no real
moral framework or foundation
it's just whatever is convenient for
them to own the cons
to gain some kind of victory there's no
morality there's no framework it is just
literally in my opinion is fire
our our country our culture is a is a
house made of brick and stone we've
built it over a long period of time
we got some weird rooms in this place
that's for sure
and then along comes new ideology that
just starts burning and destroying these
things
there's no real rhyme or reason to to
their ideologies other than
we're right and we want power but it's
just like one thing that's
i mean there's so much of this that you
could have never predicted i mean i
remember talking about some weird
virus that's going on in china in
january and seeing some weird videos and
oh but that
you know won't actually come you know
they've had stars before and it hasn't
come
but yeah so you know there's been so
much that you really couldn't predict
standing here now a year ago but the
thing that i find really striking is
people's willingness to go along with
whatever yeah i remember just like
having my jaw drop
hearing the stories and understanding
that wuhan was allowing international
flights but not domestic flights in
china
hearing that i was like wait what's
going on here i remember hearing about
the wuhan laboratory
you talked about it automatically cut on
youtube on twitter on facebook
uh just utterly deleted and and the
control of social media i think
you know you kind of talked about it a
little bit talking about how
unethical they are and how uh you know
they're just
doing things for profit and i think that
this deserves a larger conversation
because
they essentially are the ones that are
controlling communications
controlling so many important aspects of
our life that if
if it was free if information was
free-flowing we could have dealt with
this in such
a way better fashion but we judged
we judged our information right we
judged it through the lens
of ideology so instead of saying like
here's some information let's look at it
objectively let's measure it against
reality
let's have you know let's have an open
discourse we measured it against
our concerns that you know saying the
virus was from china was racist
we measured it not trump he called it
the kung flu well that was
and they told you to go to the chinese
day parade in new york city
yeah i mean you had bill de blasio and
nancy pelosi both saying come out to
chinatown stop being racist
you had them saying that trump was
overblowing the virus and then so
quickly thereafter
saying that he wasn't taking it
seriously enough and it turns out that
i think hhs under his um
under his leadership was dealing with it
in january but
we don't look at reality we don't look
at information objectively we look at it
through the lens of
you know our political priorities
and that's a real problem and that is a
problem of leadership specifically but
it's also a problem for us who keep
voting for these people who don't have
any concern other than maintaining their
own power base
but i even think that's like two meta
you know like human
functioning and like human cognition has
existed longer than like the internet
controlled our communication and people
like
you would think that there would be some
level of like functioning and thinking
that goes outside of the prism that like
big
tech and the media present information
to like
you know we were talking about how
draconian it got and
you know for instance i i got a
trespassing ticket during covid i
will trespassing trespassing um for
playing squash
in a park wow because
you know in new york they closed
playgrounds and i needed to exercise
and i wasn't about to just run around in
a circle on a track i wanted to play
with the racket
so i hopped the fence to a squash court
and got caught by police so you're
confessing
right now oh oh i've already i've
already pleaded guilty
and paid my ticket so
i'm home free but no but you know i so i
got this ticket for trespassing
playing alone in a park in a gated like
space and i was nowhere near anybody and
there was no infection that was
happening at that moment
and i got and i was thinking about the
ticket and i'm like
is there not no capacity or for nuance
to distinguish between something that's
dangerous and harmful and something
that's not like
the the how reticent people are to go
along with something that makes
absolutely no sense for the sake of just
being like a bot
for for our like ruling class i guess is
just
like that but we were talking about that
something and that has nothing to do
with the media or with tech that has to
do with your own judgment
but it also has to do with how far you
have to be pushed in order
to fight back against something right
most people pretty much just want to
live peacefully they just want to
take their kids to school they want to
get dinner on the table they want to
relax on the weekend
and so until the point comes and we were
talking about this before until the
point comes when you can't get dinner on
the table
yeah and unless you're pushed past that
breaking point
what you're going to do is you're going
to do your job and you're going to get
dinner on the table and you're going to
try and take care of your kids and
that's what you're going to do
well i i'm i'm i'm uh uh
i don't know what the right word is i'm
skeptical that the same things that led
to say the arab spring or
traditional revolutions we've seen it
with food will have will have the same
role particularly because millennials
don't have kids
it's really really easy to feed one
person
but a lot of these revolutions it's
because food is becoming too expensive
why well
people have children so when it comes to
the point where your kids are being
threatened
a person will go to great lengths to
protect
their children minos don't have any i
mean well they do
obviously but they're disproportionately
less they've got things like cockapoos
and
yeah little little little what are those
little pomeranians
yeah they look like snappy things little
yappy things
it is uh i will say though that the um
the stuff shortage in the u.s i think is
uh
getting worse my i only have one child
but my grocery bill keeps
increasing by something like 25 or 30
dollars every
every couple of weeks yeah that's crazy
my normal grocery bill for like
you know your basic trip to the grocery
store a little bacon a little
pasta and some fruit whatever who cares
this would be like 50 bucks and now i'm
up to like 125
for the same stuff we went to a local
grocery store
and i was just getting some basis i
can't remember what we were gonna make i
think we're doing like a taco night or
something and it was like 300
for not even that much meat sour cream
you know avocados and i was like this is
a mistake
and then i was like everything was just
it added up and i was like what
this is mind blowing to me like how did
it get so expensive we didn't have a
full cart
i'm buying way less meat than i used to
it's not like i was buying that much of
it but now there's just like
one night i'll make my kids some poor
child there is thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this tim channel
irl monday through friday at 8 pm where
you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you